hello and welcome everyone to today's
webinar on what makes an e-commerce
business click if you manage an
e-commerce business digital marketing is
your bread and butter
and while the basics of marketing may
never seem to change your market and the
digital economy are always evolving as
other ways the consumers behave online
what makes them tick and what makes them
click today's webinar we're going to be
joining that one but two e-commerce
digital marketing powerhouses Jeff
Ferguson the CEO and founder of Fang
digital marketing and Peter leaver CEO
of prime view they're going to be
sharing the latest research and
recommendations on the current ecommerce
market how online businesses are doing
and what's working and what's not
they'll also learn the role that digital
marketing plays and how you can use that
in any of your e-commerce business
objectives so our guest today is Jeff
Ferguson we have two guests Jeff as the
first one is a CEO and the founder of
bang marketing specializing in search
engine display social mobile marketing
and more with over 20 years of online
marketing experience Jeff has led the
online marketing efforts for companies
such as Hilton Hotels Kimberly Clark
Interactive Corp Experian and Napster we
also are honored to have theater Leafers
a CEO and the founder of prime view an
award-winning web design agency and
that's considered as a leading authority
on online marketing and business
solutions across the state of Arizona
with Peter the helm prime view has
provided startups and fortune 500
companies alike with online solutions to
meet their business needs over 20 years
of experience in the web industry he
advocates for the implementation of
data-driven strategies to reduce tangel
results and you get to hear those
recommendations for free today so
welcome again Jeff and welcome to you
too Peter two-hour webinar
thanks a bunch and always really a
pleasure to work with you guys and
everybody over it over
I'm view over at assembly rather and we
looking forward to this presentation
today I've had the pleasure of knowing
Peter Fleur oh well over a decade at
this point on Peter and I actually met
when I was speaking at a conference in
London and quite famously stood up after
the Michelle and it was kind of like
heckling me from the back about some
specific questions and I they only thing
out for a beer afterwards and I'd answer
everything you wanted to do and then we
became best friends since then I'm going
to let Peter kind of take most of the
wheel today and you'll you'll hear me
kinda come in on some specific
promotional type information and kind of
add some color to some of the things
because we obviously worked in
e-commerce for over 20 years at this
point and also want to mention that
you'll see in the beginning of slide
Peter has assembled some just fantastic
statistics about e-commerce and its
growth and things like that and we put
those in there for a really specific
reasons not necessarily to kind of sell
you on the concept of e-commerce but
because we feel it actually comes in
handy when you were trying to sell
ecommerce maybe up the channel that or
why you you know you need to get budget
away from another project or you know
why these become more important II um
they're great little tidbits of
information that you basically say this
is the reason why we have to get tackle
stuff right now if they don't know that
already
so with that in mind I'm going to go
ahead in this over to Peter and we'll
get started
makes much JEP I appreciate that so uh
lots of information to discuss today so
I'll try to be brief and again and maybe
we can ask questions as we go again
presentation so obviously it's growing
we started our company in the 1990s W is
like 40 million users now 287 million
users that's in the u.s. I actually
don't think the only people that don't
have you come to the internet access are
going to be you know my five-year-old
son and a few other people who are 80
plus even though my grandmother I'm
still ad so that's obviously growing and
it's becoming more ubiquitous in our
daily lives so but having seen that kind
of get us a viewpoint of housing
moving along and nowadays like you know
the growth of e-commerce is with 18,000
percent when we started with 2.4 billion
dollars and as of this year it's a four
to forty billion dollars of transacted
online that's in the US China is
something like 600 day so this is
obviously a huge and growing area then
you can address the next slide up to the
points that existed a Segway Jeff you
know how the richest man in the world in
the country is right now no Peter
Drummey Jeff Bezos the owner of a Nevada
ironic so as an e-commerce guy I'm very
excited that another on this guy is kind
of written the top so it's just
fascinating to watch that so when you're
looking at trends clearly you know Bill
Gates was the guy from for a long time
to get you you know a software empire
now ecommerce that's incoming is ribs in
that capacity so you can see that
there's skews it's kind of the way
things are on this slide is an
interesting fact
so 13% ball a retail that retail like
which is that all of the physical
transactions and goods are actually done
online so that's about it's about a
three trillion dollar marketplace in
terms of retail and the e-commerce is
only at 13% so there's a huge growth
opportunity we see that growing to 17%
the future which looks which adds
another eighty billion dollars in terms
of growth of how people are going to
start using their phones and stuff like
that so again ecommerce as a capacity as
a service is growing dramatically on
media and here's a huge example so that
business is flowing from companies to
like Amazon's of the world of Walmart is
trying to get back and game disagree but
I mean like like my first job was with
RadioShack talk about a company that's
no longer you know that kind of missed
the whole boat of completely got washed
out by them by that thing and that
you've seen like Sears and this is a
good UX kind of conversation but I mean
they're no longer they used to be a
strong brand but they're just in terms
of their mobile experience and their
whether they look like that they just
missed the game a company has had a
strong comeback and X passing the
destinations and a lot more engagement
on
with products and customer ISM as
posting some stronger results JC
Penney's we'll see how that goes but
these are you know these are companies
that are announcing store closures and
trying to reduce the size that they can
stay irrelevant more online it will be
anywhere kind of them right yeah and it
didn't like to that point like one of
the things I respond that's really
interesting here is if you think about
it if you think about like the history
of like retail especially in the United
States both JCPenney and Sears got their
start off as like a catalog company you
know it's just a classic no mail it to
your house and do whatever it is I mean
dated they were really kind of like the
early foundations of that type of
business
before they actually had the
brick-and-mortar kind of stores so it's
almost like they forgot to go back to
the roots when that type of business
took back over and they should have been
able to pivot a lot faster but they just
didn't move quickly enough right yeah
that's what we have the Chinese till
bankruptcies in 2017 that's you know
something like eighty billion dollars of
market share revenues they had is gone
it switched over to e-commerce and
Amazon and their competitors so trends
for 2018 these are things you should be
aware of as you're designing your
website as you're doing things about
marketing and stuff like that so the
first thing is like more than
three-quarters of online shoppers would
like how to order ship the same day so
if you live in a major city right now
Amazon does aqua see three shipping and
we're seeing vendor two starting off
that but certainly having your products
close to your customers where they can
interact with it it's going to be a is a
driving of consideration for how how
fast or how much the woman's engage with
so you know logistics is really coming
in critical it can make critical
component about how these things work
the almost two-thirds of customers would
like to receive you know if they can get
it within the hours and I think Amazon
Prime is offering the like a couple hour
delivery definitely have it where you're
at but they're storing the role that
announced Olympians domain you know
maybe so much more engaging subset where
that's good yeah out here know Los
Angeles we've got that on that type of
level and we're even see they started to
see some really interesting experiments
not just with Amazon but even with some
of the other big players in the area
like Walmart of those dimensions is
trying to get back and do it they're
doing a pretty good job and one of the
ways that they're trying to like sift
themself apart a little bit is is like
how that delivery happens to the point
to where you can even get really
specific directions as far as like
actually like letting them into your
house so that groceries get delivered in
a really specific way or nice change out
to make a difference either keep
something this evolution from the
evolution kind of thing to where it's
moving beyond just like how quick you
can get it but and like how customized
that can be you know one day they've
been talked about the idea that you know
not only will they come in the house but
you know it's like if it's food it's
right in refrigerator it's just very
ready for you when you get home not
quite ready to have some small marble
and house it but for kids or that is the
latest when they have it some of the car
companies will and I can have access to
your trunk or something like that yeah
no I don't need some hacker to be able
to get yeah but anyway that's definitely
the time to go wrong once to the noble
ever do it again right but it's China no
which is obviously a higher distribution
place to these these you know the
logistics that we're developing in the
US are have already been done is they
have such high density populations so
people are linked before they come home
they're mobile device and they'll have
groceries delivered like that neck
without the exciting stuff okay so
making a trend so uh to them but this is
an interesting stat so mobile running
commerce study by so consumers depend on
mobile phones your research products
more loud than ever to make purchases
and get even more vital investments so
the bottom line for this is people
typically have by here like an exam was
Jeff post some he posted something about
his cool uh refrigerator the cooler that
had wheels and stereo and all kinds of
other stuff and I went of course to look
online to see what the device was where
I get it um you know all that kind of
stuff so what's going on is people are
hearing about things either through
their social social areas through
magazines to print or even walking
through stories and using their mobile
devices to go find out research more
about products so the mobile footprint
that you have is influencing people's
purchasing whether it's print whether
it's a physical product in a visible
store your desktop experience or even
even the you know your mobile e-commerce
site but that is having coupons and we
see that to grow even more in the next
couple years so you know this is a 2016
that we think it's going to be at least
one point five trillion dollars in the
next year it not to trend in 2018 so
local it is kind of an interesting one
it's a little more it's not quite here
yet but you know local commerce delivery
versus drones this an explication I
don't think it's going to be accurate
but they said 16,000 commercial drones
in use by 2018 I think we're still on
the cutting edge you're trying to forget
it out most people are concerned about
you know having a drone drop in the full
current under our roof or whatever so
we're not quite there yet but there is a
significant cost savings like a 60
percent cost savings if they can figure
out how to use the drones the last mile
so you can imagine that the big
companies are looking at saving you know
hundreds of millions if not billions of
dollars but using drones they're going
to be trying to figure that out any way
they can and I wouldn't be surprised if
we see that in action at least next
clears voice voice command shopping I'm
sure you guys have heard about all the
stories of the you know the kid that
actually ordered their favorite doll
house and had a $60 $60 dial he'll show
up at their front desk because their
parents been disabled online purchasing
that is a big deal companies are
spending lots of money to be able to
integrate with my residents stuff
recently but integrate with you know
with the Amazon the series stuff like
that I mean our house we've got series
Amazon and Google Voice Google's Google
application also you know adds a voice
tool and comes to trying to figure out
how you can integrate with those tools
is to go say bye-bye
tell me some more clips I mean more of
this but we see that growing
significantly the next couple years
animation community e-commerce like you
want to be looking at that tool and
figuring out how to how you can use it
how to impact your business these from a
competitive perspective
yeah actually think this is I think
that's going to be one of the next big
battle grounds that you're going to see
on how that all comes together biz
you've got companies like Amazon and
Google that have done this this great
groundwork but making sure that
got out and and widely dispersed and
they're cheap and people love them and
they're doing a lot of like fun tricks
with them like listening to music or you
know having to tell jokes and a few
other things and you know as you
mentioned there there are you know some
things where you can order things when
they've gotten people in a certain habit
where they can kind of yell and say hey
you know ordered me paper towels and do
whatever it is but one of the really
interesting things is is that when
you've got a marketplace that we are
start asking for generic products like
that we're asking for paper towels or
toilet paper or whatever it is you'll
notice it would end especially that they
will default to sending you like the
Amazon basics kind of brand in that
instance because those are the ones that
are right there and I think when you're
you'll see as far as like the next big
like not necessarily fight but one of
the ways that Amazon will probably help
themselves make money is the idea of
instead of doing it from like a strict
you know CPC kind of battle like you did
with Adwords what it is is you'll have
brands that are vying for who gets to
show up as the default setting in that
time when there's not the default
setting being and I think that's
something like yet another way that
Amazon make money on in the kind of in
the voice search type of space and I
think Google will get to that next as
well and it like right now you know you
can you can kind of experiment with like
voice commands and things which is up in
voice search results or whatever it is
but there's no specific way to get there
um and I think you'll that's that's next
it's just a matter of like how can they
actually like monetize that network
never take money to make it all work
absolutely so that is definitely next
big thing on the scene one of the other
areas that we think is really big at not
so much it next thing but really a
powerful thing in 2018 is basically chat
box right chat box is a little box to
dump them onto the screen and your visit
website you'll see them usually on the
bottom part I almost have to consumers
list live chat is the third way to
connect right and about the same number
saying that they would they would buy
each other so what that does I mean you
know from the consumers perspective they
don't have to call sales guy they don't
have to go dig through it FAQ they don't
have to do you know send an email and
hope it gets answered they can get their
information right there and so we're
seeing that stretch into not only
business hours but 20 24/7 Mike
cases and it does as the percentage
increased conversions or standards
recommendation customers you know if you
can have a chap on your website you
should definitely do that
and nowadays you see the easier to
automate those things or to build a list
of the same FAQ or whatever they have so
again the cell reclamation
recommendation everybody is if you have
a site add a chatbot box have some
internal staff or external staff support
people do it but it does make a big
difference in sales on our sales
conversion yeah it's kind of remarkable
to see how that's grown like a or out
and how quickly as then as far as
technology goes because I remember when
you first started to see that it was it
was a real pain in the neck to implement
and now it's you know you throw a few
lines of code up in your site like you
do like so many other things with with
web and locations and it's got an easy
and now I've even seen there's a couple
companies throughout they're competing
in this space that are kind of reaching
into the the other kind of like the
messaging space to where you can get
those box integrated as well like with
Facebook Messenger and a few others
where they release you set up and it's
really remarkable if you think about it
just how quickly it's made it so you
know drag and drop you know a lot of the
box kind of solutions that do were
something before we used edit you know
had to bring in six programmers to
implement it now it's just yeah Kolani
code in a $19 application imagine a
little joke it's pretty inexpensive
okay tweet three key building blocks of
a successful e-commerce site so these
are three kind of you know critical
components and we'll go over some
suggested you know something like the
top like suggestions we have was but
let's go with the first one but music
experience so sweetie steam companies
spend tons of money on advertising to
get people to website and then that
website sucks
okay the user experience is horrible uh
you know somebody can't get around with
it the content on the website is not
engaging stuff like that so if you are
in the business to make money to baby to
commerce then you want to have quality
content and you actually configure them
in the moment in short an e-commerce
site you've got it you know have it
engaging for them that's going to help
us you know then basically you want to
make sure they experience is pleasing
for the customers there's a site load
quickly I find the navigation when I'm
looking for via navigation is a checkout
process cumbersome or Kinetoscope clicks
through really quickly but one of the
things that I mean way to have a
applique like to be able to assume in a
website that had that enabled and we
actually enabled it for some other
customers where literally you go through
you click on the item you don't have to
type in your name mission use ad your
thumbs the bottom of the phone and going
to transact that may be a little bit too
easy for my wife I think but for for
their overall end users perspective I'm
not trying to on a small screen type in
my name and my phone number in my credit
cards up like that so it really needs
elements with that with paypal and on
all these things are making it much
easier to search to buy new things in
mobile and say you know to to make it
make that experience even smooth Jeff in
terms of e-commerce or content need any
kind of input you monster well this was
you know just like ten minutes
it's a been addition comp Dayton eight
and eight the people they can can keep
it marking up it didn't revolve is it I
think it just cause more confusion that
it really helps anybody because in
reality like it you know anything this
is really content when it comes to your
website it could be blogs you could do
product descriptions it could be a fake
use it could be whatever and I think you
know one of the big discussions we've
had with so many of our clients lately
when we comes to talking about content
that lives on their website is like what
it could actually be and over and over
all day to keep defaulting this idea
that it's you know do we have to start a
blog do we have to have this thing and
we actually talked more people out of
blogging than we do into it these days
because there's so many different kinds
of different that like industry types
and things that we deal with where you
go like look nobody wants to read a blog
about like what you guys do it's not
something where you you know you've got
that kind of cadence it's not a regular
recurring thing where people are going
to check into it on a regular basis
however um you know when you think about
it in the grand scheme of things and you
know and why you're presenting that
content and you know and what it serves
as you know as far as like actually
describing your products or describing
your company or your service or or how
these things actually help things it all
comes down to this this kind of calm
that almost ties back into search every
time and you're not necessarily doing it
for search you're doing it for your
customers and for your potential
customers but like search loves it which
is you know another planet-- bonus to it
but it becomes a matter of like really
creating content with the idea of like
answering questions about what you can
do to actually solve these things and
and so that's what was in like a you
know epic use felt a lot of frequently
asked questions for Google there but
actually big they're big embolisms
wonder they're just great pop their
victims for informations that answer
these questions that helps people
decisions of you or product and service
but like I said search also boards it's
one things we're back from the
standpoint of like when you're looking
in Google for releases of a query about
like your industry in general or your
product in general and if you're the one
that's actually has got a page that's
dedicated to answering that specific
query then you're in the money pit
already found to thing goes with you
know with the we talked about full
research and a few other things that are
coming through that's how these things
finally like come together and you could
you know if you think of it at that
standpoint and kind of get out of your
head with the idea of like hey look I've
got to have a blog and kind of go out
there and pontificate about you know
like my theories forever where the
industry is going just skip it the
people get investors from these days go
more for things that were you actually
like helping sell your product in an
indirect kind of standpoint be on be a
guide for potential customers and
they'll remember you and they'll come
back and it's you know again it helps
with search it helps with you know a
variety of the things that you can use
you can end up using this in you know
social media campaigns where you're
using storytelling there's so many great
things you can do but think it all the
way through and again think of it from
the standpoint of like how you can
actually introduce your business how you
can provide answers all these things
come in a variety of topics even you
know isn't specifically about you maybe
it's about the industries as well in
general or whatever this but there's
there's plenty of ways to go without
actually being like a specific blog god
get them wrap them back into the user
experience aspect of it so the content
reinforces and shouldn't direct all the
visual experience that content of
innovation and all that process of it so
it's really a part and parcel a little
bit really important aspect of like how
do you make those visuals pop now they
say
so and then one things you'd last me get
remember are the user experience that's
it's not desktop I mean nowadays like
sixty seventy percent of our traffic is
mobile so you've got to make sure that
they music experience from the you know
iPhone six the Android you know eight or
whatever were you looking at and the
desktop are all consistent and we need
to work with them if you spend time
making those things work right then
you're going to generate you'll retain
more customers you will convert more
customers you'll do your create a buzz
button yeah and those of you that came
to my last presentation that was on like
the the coming kind of mobile first
index which section it's not coming it's
here already but the thing you know
those that concept that was now looking
at your your mobile versions of your
site as it's from form of index so just
you know start with you know mobile
start with mobile in mind because that's
just where everybody is really doing and
then just not you should ignore desktop
but keep that you know people in mind
don't make it something where you just
come to it later and said oh we probably
should do this I mean start there yet
will pick it out and and you'll be with
accident its next one okay
building trust this is one of the most
critical parts of the website so how
many people I see amazing designs of
websites look beautiful and stuff like
that but then they skip this one part
which is how do I know you're legit how
many interesting so so they're losing
business because they're not kind of
keeping the dumbest one so I was well
because six different points of one is
company's mission like how do I know how
old of the company you have like an
email address and your phone numbers
look like that so that I tip I'm
concerned about it can get back to you
so the company information is important
kind of a telling the story about what
the vision is those things help terms of
building to a return policy again one
the reason the amazons kind of outdone a
lot of you know the Walmart supply that
is really easy to send stuff back so you
know the other day I have bought some
large product videos again with
humidifier or whatever it was it didn't
work right it was a pain and I was able
to put it back in a box and drop them
off and lose population money so the
easier that people understand the return
policy is more clear it is the more
human friendly it is the better you're
going to convert a privacy policy this
is like even more
Quentin Center with the European GDP are
which is their policy mission really
have to tell people like how you're
collecting information you know what are
you going to do with it are you selling
it to 13 other you know friends and
cohorts or can I trust that you're not
Facebook if you're not selling video and
their system but customer reviews you
will talk about this this is probably
one of the biggest one of the second
biggest items online eighty-eight
percent of customers trust online
reviews as much as a personal
recommendation
so again if you're doing shopping one of
the things we'll look at is the route
number reviews and this is one of the
things I tend to look at for the site if
a site has the product has it is similar
the same they look good anchor you can't
tell difference one has more positive
reviews or the other one unlikely to buy
the one that has more positive reviews
so on your website and your e-commerce
systems need to actively solicit their
customers to get reviews um they have it
on other other website see if you can
borrow it or use those other content
content but soliciting and requesting
customer reviews is a great way to drive
closure it's calling you to more
impactful Venice um trust icon
these are seals badges logos you know
how long has it been in business are you
insured under XYZ you take know Europe
your license with go to Arabic using
Amazon or Google or whatever the more
you can establish some kind of trust
icons will see quickly in the
presentation process but more likely or
the customers will work with you and
feel comfortable enough to actually you
know give business lastly SSL this is
kind of a given this is a little
security certificate on the website if
you don't have one nowadays just a
requirement I'm not going to touch into
it do too much with that an SSL is
required to us also the really have any
intelligent let the get it okay
marketing promotion this is an area
obviously you might affect Jeff wanted
to leave mark work with these things you
know at the most absolutely so yeah so
when it comes to this one as you can't
you can't skip this level right so it's
there's so many companies we run into on
a regular basis where they've done so
much great effort into a show like just
creating these these gorgeous looking
websites on you know maybe they followed
all the great advice with Peter share so
so far as far as like building
sites with trust and always great things
to it on and then they just think that
the fact that they put the store up is
going to make all the difference in the
world right under they just think that
you know it's like hey it's fantastic
people will just find it it's a good way
to do it
and all these other kind of things I'm
oh but talking about just become like
secondary weird kind of actions where
there you go we need to do those kind of
things and and companies have been like
you know made or lost based on on not
exit eight participating these types of
activities so you know start with
branding on a identity you actually like
you need it you actually need to spend
this type of effort into it and this is
one of those things where it's so much
easier these days to actually like have
somebody create these things do it you
know obviously bad great companies like
like Peters that it can kind of help you
down this direction when it comes to how
these things get together with the
overall website design but even if you
want to take a step back and really look
at it from like an overall decision like
what your things are going to be it's so
much more than metal logo it so it's a
look it's a feel it's it's a brand voice
it's a bunch of other things that you
actually need to put together and
they've got really great companies that
can do these things for you to make it
really easy we're a big fan of actually
using 99designs
believe it or not as a company they've
got these these great kind of identity
packages that they can put together for
you where it will not just be the logo
but they'll actually take all these
other steps did design everything from
like you know if you need to stationery
or your business cards presentation the
whole thing where it's nice and concise
package that it gets it done that's one
quick easy way to kind of do these
things where it's not too expensive but
even then you've got you know some
old-school organizations that will step
in and help you do these things like oh
my god like like yeah like you guys
likes office or write of things so
there's there's so many sources that can
take you down this road and we can
really discuss it and try and get things
a point the idea that you you know to
have like a crappy logo like anymore
just doesn't there's no excuse for that
take the moment make you put your effort
and it is make sure it really kind of
tells you know who these things are it
can be done if I can configure that for
you to running and then and excitedly is
why it's important basically leave the
logo get how relevant your site is to
your customer how
books does have an impact of trust right
so if you have something that's looking
world and current touring some of the
current features and stuff like that
people more likely to trust you as being
somebody that can deliver their service
and deliver the results that we want
that you want you know you're trying to
provide and ones that don't you know
they have old-style stuff old you know
the logos and fonts or all the wrong
type or not consistent and stuff like
that that impacts of credibility in that
super so that's an important aspect of
yeah we've got so many customers that we
run into with a you know maybe they've
you know they've had it for a while and
if they've existed for a while like
there was a company we deal with a bit
dealt with education for actors and
things like that recently were they on
they you know they've got this great
businesses they built were you know
people are actually are using the
website and they're you know and they're
coming to these seminars that they throw
and all these kind of things and the
website was just awful right him it was
it was something looked like it was just
fresh out of the 90s and you know it was
built on geo spaces or something like
that and it's I've never like I was
raising and by the first thing out of my
mouth was like look I don't want to be
too insulting but it's amazing you guys
are doing so well yeah like how much
better you could do if you took the
effort into it and had somebody really
like go the extra mile lines things and
oftentimes they've you know well the
reason speed and I suppose is we're
easily will like recommend us as you
should really go talk to these my
friends over time for you first to
actually give these things cleaned up
and get it in the area and then you know
meanwhile we can write sure your bigger
plan for promoting these things and
everything so anyway that that kind of
brings us to the next step which is
social media this is one of the things
we just you can't escape it anymore it's
everywhere there's a variety different
platforms you can you can start on here
on you know we always tell people make
sure you look at those that are actually
you know where your audience is it's
still a form of media plan and the great
thing about media plan is the idea of
like finding your target audience and
where they kind of hang out first or
rather than just doing things because
that's the approach any things are going
on right now so you know if you're
dealing with a slightly older audience
or were you know so many different
directions you probably don't need to be
up on snapchat but if you've got you
know different business kind of running
type of things you know you can look
into things like LinkedIn you can look
into Twitter you can still look into
Facebook because there's plenty of
people that are that are up there being
oh everybody's on these things so
there's ways to actually do these things
and then you know you need to do it from
like both sides of the equation just
both from the organic side of it where
you're just posting and interacting and
you know making it kind of like a
community for both your existing and
potential customers and then you also
you know anymore you're going to have to
pay for it a little bit there's going to
have to be at least some form of
advertising and you'll be thankful that
you actually dig into it because the the
targeting powers and what you can
actually do with these things and how it
integrates with the rest of your content
and everything that you're doing is
amazing these days that they can do and
how to actually introduce people with
customers it's just a glorious way of
working things and yeah it's definitely
it's something you can't escape anymore
what it comes to yeah doesn't say social
media on that side things to you know so
I tell the customers like you know these
platforms spending you know it was $19
on whatsapp so for the reason they're
doing this noting that because they love
everybody but because they if they can
build a organic saga piece to certain
volume then they start cutting back on
the event the organic exposure that used
to have your post now becomes paid so
before we did one post to add like a
social media reach of like nineteen
ninety thousand people in one day
there's no way now yep so you know a
good you know you're spending money to
get that exposure on social media so if
you're thinking of social media is
organic it's good sorry but you've got
to be paid absolutely pay to put on that
kind of brings us the spigot of organic
that brings us search engine
optimization and the this is another one
where something you just kind of have to
think of like right out of the box that
kind of concept a word kind of like hey
let's get the website on we'll worry
about the stuff later it'll it'll easily
cost you more it'll be more effort later
on it's something you have to think of
like from the get-go but the cool thing
about it and in a any of you have ever
heard me speak before an SEO or where
you see mates conferences or whatever it
is you know SEO in reality is a
collection of marketing and site
development best practices that you
should be doing anyway because it's you
know it's 2018 and you own a website
right this it isn't something where you
to look at it as some type of guru or
some type of magic or whatever it is
it's really just great marketing and
it's great site development you know and
if you're working with over on the right
partner when it comes actually building
your website they'll make sure that the
technical side of things where they
sometimes they call on-page aspects of
it will be right from the get-go they'll
make sure you'll have those title tags
your Meta Description tags and we place
all those other kind of like schema type
things that you really need to have in a
place will be there from the get-go on
if they don't do those kind of things
that they look at is something where
they consider that out of scope or if
they try to to try to extra or whatever
it is get a really leery of working with
companies like that because it's
something that just should be built from
the right but it's just the right thing
to do and then when it comes to the
other aspects of it when it comes to
like content and and link building and
whatever they're there again this this
gets sold with some kind of mystifying
thing but in reality the content need
developer your website if you've kind of
followed my earlier advice about making
sure that you're answering questions or
they're really descriptive and that
you're providing great information about
your products services most of the heavy
lifting will get done for you when it
comes to you know the the SEO side of
things because you're actually like
writing great content there's you know
extra little steps you can take to make
sure that you're really speaking well to
your target audience and that's where
doing things like keyword research will
come in handy but any more like Google
and the rest of them have gotten so
smart with it that if you're even just
close they will take the extra mile and
actually get you get you there and then
link building you know they're all all
the search engines have caught on to
like the shady ways that people used to
do link building right online the best
the best way to do things thing is
really kind of look at it from if like a
public relations standpoint and again
it's just a good marketing practice that
you're just out there getting coverage
for your business and that could be you
know that you're you know the classics
like making sure that you're in all the
you know the old yellow page type
services that are out there for
different businesses but if you're a
national brand you still need to do
those things and go the step further
because you still need to get reviews
you need to you still need to get people
to talk about you you still need to go
as things that are doing that are class
like public relations style things and
in these modern day and age those things
create the best kind of links that'll
help you so like these things all wrap
together it's just part of it all
marketing plan the end up helping seo
seo sides of things and you don't have
to think about difference and then with
mobile you know i'm going to give this
back to Peter but I do want to again
just reiterate an earlier point on this
one which is the idea that you know
mobile isn't a strategy right it is
something that where you look at is kind
of like we say hey look what's our
mobile strategy how we're going to do
things Mobile is just a way of life now
there's no way to escape it majority
people are using it it's just inner
woman in anything if anybody tries to
give you like a plan or they try and
build a website whatever in mobile just
isn't included and there is just a stand
de facto kind of like as standard for
how these things work again be really
leery out the way they work because it's
just the way people work these days look
at your own usage for everyday usage for
how you use things would have just
realized how much you're on your phone
that's the rest of the world so yeah
Peters probably got some more tips on
that one oh yeah on the mobile side of
things I'm getting so you know obviously
one of the biggest things that Google is
looking at and sort of our customers is
speed you know I'm sure because mobile
can be you know with a one bar or to
Mars or whatever the case
speed is one of those really important
inspector this most important aspects of
site overall site design so we really
work with customers to make sure that
they're you know aside from the user
experience and all that other stuff but
you know that it's optimized or you know
crisper speed or engagement people can
use you know what fat thumbs can find
stuff without having to go you know
doing a hardcore searches on and stuff
like that so optimization that cool is
key element and I'm the kind of roll
person getting close on time but on
reputation management again that really
going to discuss that that really kind
of focuses back to what people are
saying about you with the brand
experiences the reviews that you have
you know all those things that are
really important and also listening to
the town or tonality of what in what
your customers experiences of so you can
intervene when necessary and also share
with them about you know the benefits
and aspects of working yeah again this
is one of those just classic reputation
manages one of those classic things
where it's integrated into something new
for the like the Internet age but it's
customer service people right
that's really where it comes down to it
you're out there you needed keeps your
that everybody's happy out there that
nobody's like talking swag about you on
the open beyond this is just the way
that business is done these days you
can't ignore it and you know the more
you start to promote yourself the more
people are going to see you and the more
people are going to comment you have to
get involved you have to do things up
and one last again like free tidbit on
this one when it comes to the word
reputation management there are a ton of
companies out there that are so on this
is a service and again if they're big
strategies out there is actually just to
create a bunch of like hokey content
just to push down the rest of that like
your bad reviews or whatever it is just
run screaming away that's actually not
the way to do it there's better ways to
do these things it's going to take a
little bit more work but in reality will
serve you in the long run so these are
some fun case studies that we put
together just getting quick stories
about customers of mindset because
enjoyment with Ndoye had some success
that might be relevant for people so
cookies from home is a 36 year old
client basically they basically
obviously there were some cookies not
from the house obviously but it's a
small it's a small like mini factory of
something when we first came to them
they had no they came to us and they had
no mobile website at all they were you
know hit it they were complaining about
the website winning clunky it was just
it was it was somebody I think put it
together and they just didn't know what
they did so subsequent to that we've
added the mobile experience for them
we've added shipping options in and out
in ship nationwide and shipping cookies
and not like shipping uh you know
product license so heat temperature oil
and stuff had an impact and freshness
easily so we didn't time work with them
to create the experience for customers
they could actually I get what they're
looking for quickly they can do mobile
you know they have Nero mobile dollars
your mobile transaction on to be on the
phone and now they've missed I think
they're the forty to fifty percent in
terms of mobile traffic you know so
that's the big shift from their revenue
and it's made a big difference in
customer experience
so they're having a lot more just all
our survey to get customers are much
more happier engage now
endurance this is a really cool high-end
fitness company basically they're their
target market for that product is
a nutritional supplement or waitlist
wait the three weight losses up like
that so but when they came to this they
had a platform that really didn't work
very well they had limited flexibility
we've added to that Apple pay we've tied
to their warehouse system they have you
know affiliates now before they had no
way to track with you know nobody can
just like Amazon nobody could actually
they wanted to buy something in refer
friendly they have no way to actually
figure out what the calculations are now
they can do that website so we've really
been able to help them change the their
business experience so the website
controls all the different aspects of
what they're doing for you know for the
athletes what they're doing for the
affiliates out of shipping products out
of color often coupons we know that
women too now and driven by Mac
environment having an impact in their
their bottom line still more like this
is kind of a fun type if you're looking
for any deals on bags or jewelry's or
whatever this company actually has a ton
of those products available they have
and they're offered at a discount which
is you know I think there's secondhand
in some cases the exterior also but
they're able to acquire products but
what's fun about it is they have you
know we've set it up so they can use
affiliates but they also have multiply
channels so in other words website is
one channel but they also sell products
in eBay there's some stuff with ft or
selling stuff and Amazon so they have a
variety of different we call it
omni-channel multi-channel environment
where their products are displayed and
pushed it variety of different elements
to get exposure in each one of those is
jiff driving in sales to get the Hat
illusion so it also impacts the brand in
the positive or grand a visible mixed
budget okay top ten actual tips to grow
your business so these are ten tips that
would run through a nomination short
since we'll kind of quote sometime these
are top ones of mailing lists when
people actually have mailing lists that
they don't mail to exactly shocking
policy usually this is a great way to de
monetize and get exposure for your
business to actually reach out to
customers because it's much easier to
self an existing customer event of you
so um sixty percent of customers have
Rayland list a purchase you know they
get a email from Amazon or other
companies you know this applies
think that generates in just that
generates buzz so by all means if you
have a mailing list you should monetize
it with at least a monthly poem
different communal things you can do
meals like that yeah and they just do
and just to take this next step like
once you've got this email list
don't don't limit yourself just the
concept of using it just for emails
right you've got those lists you can use
them as in to make custom audiences and
things like Facebook on Google AdWords
again so many other platforms so you can
actually upload those lists into the
source and actually have these great
matching systems in place and we
targeted another way I'm a big fan of
doing that because I will be the first
one to tell everybody that email from
great suck and we've all been convinced
that that you know 20 to 3 percent is
solid when in reality you know any other
medium where you only get that type of
exposure rate on something you would
kill it long ago it's a good thing that
email is cheap otherwise we probably
would have stopped using a little time
ago but you can actually use visit lists
uploaded into these other platforms the
exposure rate is much higher
um and you can expand the reach of that
that list to way beyond what you're used
to doing there's all kinds of cool
things you can do there that we're
actually working with implementing to do
like another entire seminar on using
this types of things so get ready for
that online free shipping problems
biggest reason people will abandon
shopping carts that they represented
with unexpected results so I got a cool
product I'm on a ship to my house I
realized it's 44 dollars in shipping and
that's that um so people so guys this is
one of the biggest ways to actually to
kill your businesses don't offer
appreciate the standard nowadays but one
of the things you can check is like hey
I'll get free shipping for anybody
that's operating quads over $50 or some
point that coupon is something like that
that will help you move the numbers so
example is if you have a sale for $35
but if they get free shipping at 50
people will often look for the tenant
$15 different so they can add that in
and get the free shipping and now you've
got instead of 100 sales of $50 you have
thousand sales assuming when Taylor $35
you on sales at $50 the price margin on
that thing you can make a big difference
between them so offer free shipping
any different ways like that by all
means make sure it's part of the mix
product reviews we talked about before
I'm not going to get too deep into it
and basically you know you want to
basically a 60% of all participants and
all customers are more likely to
purchase and recite the product reviews
so make sure you have that on the side
if you're offering it you have some
available because that really is a big
deal there's a lots of great software
tools to reach out to customers that
have made purchases and ask them for
feedback and some things but this should
be part of your mix it will make a
difference in sales promise
techno Niall satisfied satisfied
customers in the home base this is
optional depending on where you're at
but 90% of customers will review the
community's reviews previous reviews on
this statement 80% of them trust online
reviews of when considering a business
so if you can add these testimonials
from different credibility you'll see
this you see a variety of look at any
website from the service company more
obviously you know president CEO of X Y
needs at this is great that stuff adds
credibility and people when they're more
likely to believe that with you no
matter how great the website is applies
time to find them in front of loyalty
program we're going to award frequent
customers encourages at one time buyers
to return your store the average
conversion ratio is roughly one to three
percent when you hire one job up but and
a conversion role conversion rate for a
repeat customer is 60 to 70 percent so
if you're going to sell the customer is
it's better to tell the existing
customer and than anyone for sure I
think it's some of the things you can do
with these rewards to get excited again
for shipping this would be things people
excited about points they can exchange
for free products so you get you know
you buy so many products 50 points pre
this or discounts discounts are and
exporters early access to new product
lines so you've got something new coming
out you can be the first one in freebies
for penis a tank you know paying a
certain amount towards you you can do
over a thousand dollars in sales we're
gonna give you X Y or Z so a loyalty
program is a great tool to incentivize
your listing customers and have
come back and have a mic go social media
social media obviously had an impact and
all those all things lab you know people
use it as a reference what I think we
covered this we throw this open but if
75% of people will buy something because
they've seen on social media platforms
so if you're not on social media you're
missing out a community aspect a bit a
bit
Princeton a slide number seven make you
only unique selling proposition clear
and prominent so it makes I'm not going
to find the company's unique position in
the marketplace so if you you know if
you're if you do something we have a
process that's really your their company
is older than most of your competitors
you have more experience expensive
restaurant on USP will articulate your
specific benefit one of your kind of
customers don't have and want to make
you stand out so this is one of these
you work with customers on to try to
create it they don't have one already
but this makes a difference like why why
it's going use bang digital widely used
to find you
these are aspects of like what makes
people want to work with you so we
recommend it as part of your own mix of
the overall definition to the front up
some slide the latest one atom has it's
great partners if you decide to partner
with an advertiser asked for methods but
for the sponsors are open rate reach CTR
other data I can't tell you how many
times we built in our opinion right
great looking websites and companies
choose markers that they like but they
have no experience they don't understand
the marketplace they don't know how to
move the ball in the archives in some
cases have lost money because their
marketing team didn't have the capacity
to work with them who didn't understand
their marketplace or really you know
just didn't get this you can get
Japanese more stories in that ones
unless you it means very similar type
times a minute member olivierb
present-day partners I kind of said it
earlier which is that times these these
classic considered businesses may be you
know they're not
whistles you know you should pay
attention well but it gives the idea of
you gotta go where your audiences you
know fish where the fish are biting is
that you could say you know the content
of what you can't just follow things
because that's the things that are doing
you got to do the research you got to
find out over that audience hangs out
who the people are going to interact if
they were really going to you know
engage with your with your company in
those environments and then they're
really big things is is university beast
great both you know metrics that Peter
you know built into the slide here will
I cooperate region at CTR whatever but
no those are all what we call diagnostic
metrics in the business those are the
things that actually like helps you
answer bigger questions like wire sales
down or wire sales up you know why is
the cost change whatever it is it does
the real KPIs kpi's actually have to do
with things that are actually really
driving your business and all these
other things that you're getting from
these are the vectors they're actually
not going to be like your real goals
just they're going to be a things that
actually just help you solve your goals
but don't get caught up too much in the
wrong metrics they're really for the
overall efficient and speaking that the
next slide is appropriate I think
connects the same question yeah um
reduce excessive actors measure success
with accuracy some ecommerce is seasonal
comparing that you compared each of each
year against another
you know Porter we may not give you the
exact results so we're looking for is
like looking at like one that we have
customers now is soon that are already
preparing for the fourth quarter sipping
for holiday season most companies are
actually in the process now that they're
looking at what kind of things I want to
put it on a runs open so you don't want
to be like you know hey it's July 4th
you know tomorrow which thing I should
we send out a newsletter you need to be
thinking about these things well in
advance
designing for them and taking advantage
of you know the strategy of being able
to reach out and create these campaigns
and looking at your traffic flow to
figure out what's what's engaging most
not yeah and again just to take that a
step further you know that seasonality
that the Peter talks about you know
obviously year-over-year seasonality is
an easy one right you know you know that
is you know when holidays come you know
you know if this person is sock or nod
you know all these things in it because
that's this way it is but you know go
deeper
we've got seasonality things that we do
it that are into a month that we see on
a regular basis that really change out
we've got one of our clients that is
works in the healthcare business as far
as you know providing you know supplies
for left home healthcare types of things
in we've noticed after having them for
about three months now where we can see
like an intra much seasonality that is
to be tied to things like when people
are getting their their checks for like
Medicare or for Social Security or
things like that on a regular basis
because they had to have to save up and
make sure they've got the cash that you
like make those purchases in those
instances it's a completely different
ballgame so don't you know get to go on
both a macro and a micro level and
really kind of pay attention these
things and that way you're not
necessarily like freaking out when
you've got like what you would be
received to be like a bad week you know
that you know the last week of the month
might always be a bad week there's
something the way it needs to go and
then you can learn to play with things
you know really good at agency that's
working with you will start to determine
these things they'll know how to make
those adjustable so that you've got
budgets actually like it's the right
types of things so and again like again
an omission is in slide eight again make
sure you're paying attention to the
right metrics here like you know if
you're thinking about things like
cost-per-click or just a number of
clicks of the number of impressions
where it is you know those are all
diagnostic metrics they're not really
what you're going after for everything
that the true metrics that you should be
worried about are the things that
actually tie back to some type of
revenue in your company rather than it
be actually ecommerce sales where there
could be a lead it could be anything
along those lines but they're cut it's
going to be something that makes you
money right and if impressions don't
actually make you money then it's not
the most important thing right it's just
don't get caught up on metrics or doing
things just follow the money and you'll
be way happy yep find him and bounce
demanding spot would over and under
buying inventory try to figure out how
many sales you have each for and make
necessary adjustments same thing we just
talk to me basically I did one customer
is a Segway not it it is but I had one
customer that he again um was selling
unique products and he wanted
best deal kept wearing the best the
opening so you have a pricey blizik
way out of line over everything else
those competitors that he had all the
seen majorities sitting there tied up in
cash the type of cash tied up initially
so finally was it we had many
discussions he was willing to bring his
print them and he was able to convert
the inventory into cash and buy more
stuff with generating 11 so now he's
much happier because it's got a much
smaller larger sale monthly sales versus
great super high prices and stuff that
they'll be fine you want and I want I
want to point this out what problems
dyslexic everyone just I want to bring
this one thing up where we're talking
about this one so that type of level of
detail right where you're talking about
like that balancing demand and supply
dealing with inventory things whatever
those are really like just business
decisions right those are just just
strong business decisions but in reality
you know like your advertising agency
and maybe your website design company or
whatever it is you're doing usually
wouldn't get involved right those are
really things to do it but the good ones
will anyway right you know like I know
Peter and I are both been doing this
forever and we've you know like I didn't
love got my MBA Peters had been doing
this for long enough to where he knows
all these all the Pistons or how
businesses work all these things all
work together and we're usually more
than happy to kind of give you that kind
of free advice to really just you know
help your business run better not just
your advertising campaigns and not just
your e-commerce I think users what
bigger consults of things how to provide
different like I say it's usually
something that it is truly above and
beyond when it comes to that type of
relationship yeah you want to look
inside you want to open up for any
questions considering its close to 60 on
yeah
well go ahead yeah we're going throw it
back to Dan does I know we're we're
you're almost better you're and and
we'll we'll see what we got here but do
you know like this deck will be
available and there's some other things
you're in that conclusion but for the
most part we've covered them all ready
to go wonderful yeah well thank you
thank you too we actually have a couple
of questions coming in here one of which
is I'm just someone asked I'm just
starting out so I'm on a small shop what
type of people do I need to
get this going who do I need to hire
what skills are essential that I can't
do myself
job if you know I know I started start
with this way so on a small shop so I
think you want to look into you know it
may not actually may not make sense to
put all your inventory online you're
going to look to see what kind of
immature you have that's relevant that's
people are you know excited by what's
possible for you and then Internet
question you want to work with a company
that has some experience in this stuff
because you need to define your target
market like movies likely to Bible and
design what is design your messages or
whatever it is to put them together with
that group right and then once you have
that group set up that's where you put
in deep into tenant you can use
certainly like guests coming to help
research and furthers but you're looking
for a company that can help you
translate the architecture of the
e-commerce stuff have something that
looks professional engaging and then be
able to go after your yeah so one of
these are really just in a big general
sense as far as like what a constructor
like you know like the people you need
and the resources you need for stuff is
do is just to get it the hell off your
plate right in like year especially if
you're a brand new company even if
you're a medium-sized business disk and
so on and like retail for a while and
you're expanding into ended digital just
to be able to sell these things on
whatever it is there are so many
companies that can help you with these
types of things you don't even you know
don't necessarily have to be prime
viewing things
there's tons of NAFTA and work with but
on get this thing off your plate there's
so many people I've rented ooh over the
years where they really try and do this
stuff and I'm all for learning more
about it these environments they've got
a really great understanding so you can
be knowledgeable when you're working
with other vendors that are actually
doing area looking for you but let me
just say like you know what but what
Peter and I do is a profession these are
things we do every day I was like in the
same sense that you know like I'm not
going to try and do my own plumbing and
electrical work around my heart because
that's not what I do for a living right
there's there's people that are their
professions on this stuff and word some
of them write in and there's tons of
them others out there that oh you know
either now
go to school for this type of stuff but
you can actually you know they've been
doing it long enough that they it's
become a profession they've got ways to
do things and you can they can actually
like help you these things in it if
you've never just touched marketing
before whenever whatever it is it's not
just a matter of like hey I've read a
couple articles in this thing and I'm
ready to go it's like get some help
it'll be worth it it'll save you a lot
more money in the long run
yeah and of course there's if there are
a whole bunch of courses you can
actually take online that simply limit
for example due to bone up on a lot of
skills should pay per click as well in
addition to the to the agency route to
but also I have a specific question
about email that someone's asking said
said I'm a little I'm shockingly late to
the game on gdpr
and you were mentioning email list and
what do I have if I have an email list
where I can't tell if I have people on
that I haven't asked for geolocation so
I don't know if they fall into that gdpr
how do I know if I'm safe to email them
so there's a couple things you want to
do Jack you know mine off just went
through a whole experience of that so um
there's a couple things you want to do
if you can your list you want to scrub
all your European you're out there take
a look you know there's ways to look at
that who's just from Europe and who's
not so you can amend audience you should
be seventeen years ago if you don't know
you we recommend that most companies
that for any kind of sides they look at
GDP are just adding the privacy and the
other stuff in there but you want to
reach out to customers to look at what
privacy policies you currently are
offering um if you again I would
probably go look at the Inca car
compliance is you know setting up
privacy policy in the website adding the
cookies says you were using it so forth
we've initiated this in a number of
different websites but that would be the
safest way to go you don't want to get
tangled up with you know somebody we hit
and Emma we have one customer from who
is Irish up working cool with other
clients that will go home and Ireland
and pay the bill you know their bill on
the website so that would technically
entangle our client into the GDP our
quanto react either block it off the
other notes and
emails or really make sure you scrub
your list and make sure that were
compliant right I guess when you're
building a list it's important to make
sure that you you get that geolocation
on there too but sometimes you can't
tell by the by the URL if it's a de you
know it's a Germany and UK line those
are obvious but yeah you don't want it's
very easy to catch it out because it is
like a million dollar fine or something
like that oh yeah what is in your movie
that'll teach him so uh would you garden
is the is the idea that it's like is you
know it's got a little bit overly
complicated and it does it freaked
everybody out in there and there's tons
of things where they just made it sound
like it was the end of the world and
then the finds are big so there's
something you obviously need to pay
attention to but you can break it down
into like three like big simple things
and the idea is that obviously you need
to let people know that you're using
cookie cookies and collect another in
for you know personal information on
your website there's so many easy ways
to do it where you've got pop-ups and a
variety of things you can let people
know you have to update your privacy
policy and if you don't have one at all
you need to put one up there there are
actually some great services out there
that'll help you build that privacy
policy and setting there's a gradable
process you can actually let me check
box this stuff and and we'll build it
out for you just based on the things
that you use or whatever it is it's very
easy to do and then third what Peter
kind of got too near the idea that if
you've got personal identifier
information or information you collect
you know you need to let them know that
you know that it's out there you need to
reach out to them again that deadline is
passed you know like the twenty-fifth
was when this one into place but you can
still actually like send it out and say
hey this these things are placed we've
made the changes we've we've updated
things or at the very least you just say
like I'm this list is just a washdown we
can't do but it does speak to everything
it's not just like sending out emails
it's also if you're using things we're
using custom audiences and wherever you
know that information counts as well
obviously those other platforms used it
on they've made their own updates to gjd
and gdpr that they've let people know
about so it's all kind of ties together
but yeah if you're even if you think you
like the smallest website in the world
and you don't think it is or is like we
only do business in the US take the
extra steps and make sure you're covered
anyway because you just don't want to
mess with us
great well that's good
well you know we are we're out of time
at the moment so thanks again Jeff and
Peter for joining us today
now for all of those who registered
through WebEx please keep an eye out for
a follow up email soon in a couple of
weeks here and we'll have a link to the
video recording and including a write-up
as well so you can share with your other
team members and I read appreciate all
the thought leadership you brought here
Jeff and Peter thanks for joining us our
pleasure in the end your you know again
we've got it up on the screen right now
if you need to get out to Jeff and Peter
you can get any other further questions
you can get us directly by our emails
there you know if you want to catch us
on social media you can do it there we
love all the questions that come in
through that aisle plus you can find me
I'm very active on Quora as you get in
other questions that you want to like
invite me in and do that as well we're
happy to help
great thank you both very much and we
look forward to hearing working in the
future hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here